[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Christan
how can we
help hey how y'all doing good how are
you sir good good so make this short and
brief um I'm 25 I got probably about 30
30 plus thousand in depth um I'm a tower
hand I make make roughly on an8 hour day
$200 a day but I got a car loan that I
haven't you know that I got to pay for I
got medical debt that's collection um
here recently um I just had the state of
Mississippi come after me for child
support um so they're going to be coming
after me pretty quick for that um I'm
I'm gone I work Monday through Friday
I'm home on the
weekends uh I'm just trying to figure
out some way to basically get more
Financial Freedom and get out of debt
and have a have a better lifestyle I
reckon okay
um so let's start first things first uh
so you're making what about 5,000 bucks
a
month uh 4500
4,000 I'd say I'd say more closer to
like 36 on the good month okay is that
after
taxes yeah okay um and you said you've
got around 30,000 of debt do you know
the exact
number um no ma'am okay that's thing one
the first thing here is to in order to
get organized to understand what the
problem is we've got to see it for what
it is so when you get off the phone
today I want you to go check all the you
know log into all those accounts and see
exactly what the debt is if you could um
sparse it out what type of debt is it
you may not know the exact amounts but
can you tell me what type of debt it
is uh more like personal loans and stuff
like that for the vehicle auto loan you
know and and I just know when I look at
it on my uh like some of my credit apps
and stuff like that they just say
they're in collections and stuff you
know so is everything in
collections I believe so okay so right
now it just kind of it's like you've
been going along all this stuff is
happening and you're just kind of like
letting it take place the fact that
we're not really sure what the debt is
we're not really sure how much the
amount is do you kind of see this theme
playing out
here well I got I got some of my uh some
of my debt mainly the aolone and a
couple of the uh couple of the health uh
like Hospital loans or Hospital
collections I got them in a a debt
relief program I pay like
$380 a month for them to basically keep
it in a a savings account and they
negotiate prices with them and hey
Christian Christian listen I'm G I'm
gonna shoot you straight we're gonna get
you some help he he needs one of our
coaches but let me tell you what I think
you need to hear your hands have not
been on the wheel mhm you you are just I
don't even know I don't think it's Jesus
Take the Wheel but somebody has taking
the wheel and it ain't you and you
listen nothing nothing against you at
all I'm trying to be a wakeup call to
you you've got you got children you're
supposed to be supporting and you're not
and the state's coming after you and
everything's just been kind of like I'm
letting life happen to me and I think
you need to start happening to life so
one of the things that you need to start
to do is as Jade said is get aware of
what's going on and I want to give you a
free session with one of our financial
coaches but you have got to do what they
tell you to do the second thing is you
better start making some more money you
you need to be working crazy hours with
the skill set you have because that will
help you do what Jade's coaching you you
got to get some more income and start
putting it to
work well see I also that's uh a
question is is I pay I pay a lot in rent
you know um I live by myself I have a
service dog but I live by myself and I
live in a three-bedroom single wide
trailer and I pay $1,200 to live change
that you know go live with somebody
else well see with with the with the the
state of Mississippi wanting child's
Sport and I figured later on there might
come a a a child's a child custody case
I also need somewhere to call my own
with that room for my for my child well
we cross that bridge when we get there
or go get your two-bedroom you getting
all this you getting this mess cleaned
up it's what's going to ultimately even
give you a dog in that hunt but right
now you don't have a dog in the hunt you
got to get your mess cleaned up and
you've really got to show that this
matters to you cuz right now I hear a
guy that's kind of like if it happens
cool if it doesn't happen no big deal
like there's you got to go somewhere and
find that enthusiasm to really make this
happen for yourself get out of that debt
consolidation thing that ain't working
for you create your free every dollar
budget today the simplest way to budget
for your life